hello everybody and welcome to awesome
comics your one-stop shop for everything
comic book entertainment I am your host
Walter burn AZ AK and today is a special
bonus episode we are talking about
season three of Marvel's agents of
shield and we have two regular guests
but they're special to me I'll start
with you on the right who are you Brian
Porter Brian Porter I'm Walt amazing as
I said before let's repeat stuff okay so
if you didn't see earlier this week on
Monday we came out with our review for
DC's legends of tomorrow season one so
make sure you go check that out that
also has a different pick of the week on
it our comic book pick of the week so
make sure you check that out and then
come back to see Marvel's agents of
shield season 3 yep okay overall what
are our thoughts on the third season in
the show it's been going pretty strong I
think for three seasons now I think most
people are on board with it after the
first season people kind of iffy on it
and then civil every night's of war but
Winter Soldier came out and I changed
the landscape of things and people I
think I've been on board for the most
part since then so what do you guys
think overall season 3 I was ok with I
mean there was some soul parts but I I
stuck with it season 3 was a heck of a
role economy you guys as you can see my
favorite character is Simmons and
Fitzsimmons forever my OTP I love them
and boy it was I didn't know if I was
gonna make it through the season cuz if
some things happen and didn't know if
I'd be okay with the season 4 but I'm
obviously ok with season 4 so spoilers I
love them now they end up down down
population them right right
I'm sorry I I love the season it's
gotten a lot better every season it's
just it's just expanding on the
everything good makes it even better
yeah a lot of rollercoaster ride for
this season a lot of liked ups and downs
for various characters and story arcs
I like the revenge play with Coulson and
Ward like how they kind of like brought
Ward back is hive thought that was
really cool yes I love Fitz and Simmons
finally getting together agree i I was
telling him if they died in the season
finale I would've stopped watching I
would have stopped well what do you - I
just wanted to hug her
like the whole time there was some Resta
I was worried about after season two and
what they were gonna do season three and
then I thought almost a but really fast
and then they didn't and I was like you
guys I loved all this stuff on the other
planet like that one episode was just
Simmons 4722 hours episode but no that
was a really good change of pace for the
the series I think that it was a very
unique episode we got to see all of
mammoths I think was the name of the
Maeda the planet but it was yeah it was
really different kind of episode for
shield and we got to see Simmons go
through all that stuff by herself it was
very interesting she's been getting some
good character stuff they'd like
downplayed it a little more in this
season and she kind of took more yeah I
was gonna say she but like her as an
actress is amazing and she has some
really good action in this season's
awesome referencing it maybe anyway so
okay what were some of you guys favorite
stuff from the season what like I know
you said Fitz and Simmons anything else
that really like drew you into this
season that's good exactly he actually
like as an actor has been really great
this season we were talking a little bit
the way that he's able to play the
other characters Wow you know that was
pretty cool
yeah yeah and it was and you could tell
what's going on including like the later
episode with the memory machine and
stuff yeah he has some cool stuff with
that as well I'd like to Coulson in this
season had some really cool stuff that
he had to work through that's he finally
got to crush I liked Coulson story arcs
to especially with that one chick that
it was the camera her name I'm from the
ADC yeah I like that like her getting
shot and you know or two guys in like
the first min of the episode I'm dealing
with that and then his rage unbridled
rage and how they dealt with his hand
they referenced it love how he had the
ax mounted on his wall I thought that
was great a lot of cool touches with the
hand what they were able to do with that
for the most part I think the show is
very focused on her every single season
which is a little bit but she still it
flowed well and everybody else had their
own time I really liked bobbi and Hunter
their exit I was gonna say very
emotional yeah in the tears it was just
oh yeah more than I thought I mean I I
liked those characters but I wasn't like
super invested in hunter and Bobbi but
when like their exit was handled so well
that you really felt like these people
were losing their friends they're
probably not gonna ever see them again
yeah they really play yeah Hunter's a
great character he's just really funny
and
to piggyback about what you said about
hive and stuff I think Brent I think
people when they look at the season I
think they should he might be looked
over Brett dome as as Ward /hi he really
changed everything
his speech patterns it just his whole
aura like how we stood everything was
completely different for highs than it
was for Ward and you is totally
believable in the first second you seen
that this is a completely different
character and it was just done so well
by him I really wanted to give big props
to put Brett dome also we got the there
was one of the fight sequences I can't
think of the character's name but we got
some of the metahuman stuff going on
that was really cool and we got the
Ghost Rider a Jacob Cohen blowhard he
was he was pretty cool to really come
back once we like his banter with maze
totally played got to see some curry
which was dope we got to see some actual
Kree
come on fight hive and stuff that was
half did you guys like lash I thought
was really cool yeah you know with the
one thing I wish it was a great reveal
when the health care but the the plane
opens I wish that they would have had a
little bit more bigger fight there I
thought they were going to be cool to go
on like should've been a big fight I was
like we could have gathered
yeah yeah you could have grunted it and
kind of like yeah but it was a great
reveal I think like I thought that was
really interesting I was really mad at
first it was a little weird
Ike was actually hi you know was awesome
like he looked he was anything that you
thought kind of missed the mark this
season anything big that were negatives
for you guys the Daisy thing kind of got
like marginally annoying because like
it's always so Daisy centric and Daisy's
love and Daisy Daisy
reason behind is kind of frustrating too
especially the season but in general she
kind of is a brat sometimes with her
reasoning behind things cuz she's sort
of goes you guys are wrong here's my
reasoning and even if some other people
might
sometimes I'm like just stop and listen
to what they're saying they have reasons
behind what they're saying so every once
in a while especially the season that
kind of got on my nerves
where I just wanted to be like Shh right
but now I mean with her going forward I
don't know what they're gonna be doing
because like that that six months six
months ahead it's established that coast
is no longer the director of shield and
obviously they've grown since then and
basically but yeah I didn't really like
that part and hopefully next season they
write scale back on some daisy stuff I
got you a focus on some more characters
all right we're gonna have to wrap this
up really quick are you guys excited for
season four absolutely yes I'm excited
to see where that goes and there's more
expansions I'm sure more characters
coming very excited about that fits in
really quickly we have a little bit of a
pick of the yeah we get extra pick of
the week you guys um so we have Ages of
shield the comic out now this year so go
check it out I love this cover this is a
to call sign has a penis I know Walter's
also I don't super like what's going on
with Fitz in May talk to me about it
because let's be real it's Fitz and
Simmons but in general I really like
Coulson in this and I really like that I
can read everything in their voices
definitely once once watching the show
and now reading this it's really
interesting to see like how your brain
can do that that's cool stuff go check
out and check it out it's some cool
artwork some cool stories going on we
get to see some extra stuff yeah okay
cool all right
whoa where can we get funny guys in the
social media cancer wrap to supper in
that Porter face blue dot-com / awesome
Porter you know talk to me send me a
message tell me what you like tell what
you don't like talk to me talk to you on
Facebook and Twitter as always come talk
to me about Fitzsimmons only if you like
them because you're not right you can
find me on Twitter at awesome underscore
Walter go ahead and give us all follow
I hope you enjoyed this the mini review
of Marvel's agents of shield season 3
like I said go back and check out DC's
legends of tomorrow he's one review that
we did on Monday also make sure you
stick around for next week because we
will be talking about the flash season 2
we're all really excited to talk about
the flash and we're also be reviewing
x-men apocalypse so come back for that
and until next time I'm multiple days
and for these lovely people here we will
see you on the next page